engineer engineer.
Dr. Zakarmon
Albakyu.
Um his name is Tju. He's an engineer
Muslim. First he thanks you for coming
to Indonesia and Jakarta and uh uh
honoring us with your uh lectures. You
know thanking you. He's asking the verse
of Quran surah al bakar surah number two
verse number 120 which is related to the
topic today. How can we harmonize or how
can we understand this verse? How how is
it applied uh to the theme or the uh
lecture today?
The brother has posed a question from
the Quran Bakar 2 verse 120 which says
which means the Jews and the Christians
will never be satisfied until you follow
their brand of
this is a verse of the Quran talking
about the Jews and the Christians that
you will never be satisfied. However
much you try to satisfy them they will
never be satisfied until you become a
jur or a Christian before this verse
before this surah bakar chapter 2 120 if
you read surah bakar chapter 2 verse
number 111
it says
they say the Jews and the Christian that
you Muslims you shall never enter Jenna
unless you become a Jew or Christian
Allah says
tell them
this is the wishful thinking
produce your proof
but if you're truthful so this is in
context if you read the first few verses
it says that the Jews and the Christians
they say that we shall enter Jenna none
shall enter Jenna unless you become a j
Christian so Allah tells them this is
the wishful thinking.
Tell them
produce your proof but if you're
truthful and the Christians that produce
the proof the Bible in no less than
2,000 different languages they say my
Bible says this my Bible says that my
Bible says this my Bible say what do you
have to do you have to swallow the Bible
hook line and single when they show
their proof you have to analyze so in
this talk of mine I'm giving the reply
I'm analyzing
in this talk
that when you check their buran, the
Bible
and if you mean Christian means the
person who follows the teachings of
Jesus Christ peace be upon him. We
Muslims are more Christian than the
Christian themselves. So my whole talk
was based on the false allegation by the
Christian missionaries.
So this talk is in reply to that
Allah says
produce your proof. Now when they
produce the proof, you should know how
to analyze the proof. If you have not
read the Bible, how will you reply to
them?
So therefore one of the techniques of
doing dawa as I mentioned in my talk in
surah Imran 3:64
come to common terms as between us and
you which is the first term Allahill
that we worship none but Allah
that we associate no partners with him
that we erect not among ourselves lords
then paid other than Allah
if they turn if they turn back
that we are Muslims bowing our will to
Allah subhanaa tala. So this full talk
is based on this concept only that when
they boast that we shall only go to
Jenna no one else will go. So Allah says
the Jews and the Christians will never
satisfy unless you follow their brand of
religion. Even if you try and satisfy,
even if you wear the cross, they will
not be satisfied until you become a Jew
or a Christian. So they're calling you
to the false path. So you have to tell
them, get your buran and you come to the
straight path. Hope that answers the
question.